David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 99-25, that is a reproduction not from the original, but from the Spool 9-25 which was reproduced from the original before the latter was damaged in its first section.
David Boder: This is Spool 25, taken from Mister Jacob Button, a Spanish Jew, who lived in Greece, in Salonika. Mr. Button is very worried that the data will not be in proper chronological order, but we have convinced him that we want especially his personal experiences. This spool is from the collection of the Illinois Institute of Technology.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Button, sagen Sie mir noch einmal, was ist Ihr voller Name, wie alt sind Sie und wo sind Sie geboren?
Jacob Button: Ich nenne mich Jacob Button, bin in Saloni—, Salonika geboren, und bin heute 41 Jahre alt. Es tut mir leid, dass ich auf deutscher Sprache spreche—und möchte mich besser französisch oder griechisch oder hebräisch ausdrücken...aus Notwendigkeit macht es auf Deutsch.
David Boder: . . . der, Herr Button, wenn Sie sich in Hebräisch ausdrücken wollen, und wollen etwas repariert haben, vielleicht haben Sie es fertig dann bis morgen—eine andere Unterredung, und ich werde Sie bitten dann, für mich eine halbe Stunde hebräisch zu lesen. Ist das gut?
David Boder: Ja, ich glaube, dass mich bemühen zu machen.
David Boder: Gut.
Jacob Button: Von...
David Boder: Also wollen wir jetzt dann mit der Sache vorwärts gehen. Herr Button, wo waren sie wenn der Krieg anfängt?
Jacob Button: Zum Anfang des Krieges war ich in Saloniki, und hatte ein Geschäft. Und von [pharmazeutische?] Produkte—und wollte niemals—ob ich Deutsch sprachen, Deutsch kenne, niemals mit Deutschen zu tun haben. Und dass ich mich von den Deutschen fern [gestepp?]. Ich wurde als Spanier zu den letzten Juden in Saloniki festgehalt.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Also, Sie sind in Saloniki geboren, aber Sie waren spanischer Untertan?
Jacob Button: Ja, ich bin separat...
David Boder: Ja?
Jacob Button: . . . und auch Spanier als Staatsangehöriger.
Jacob Button: Und aus diesem Grunde wurden wir zu den letzten Juden von Saloniki weg—, äh, weggejagt wurden—worden.
David Boder: Nun, äh, sagen Sie mal, äh, hat man die anderen Juden zuerst genommen?
Jacob Button: Ja, man hat erstens die griechischen Juden versammelt und nach einer kurzer Aufenthalt in einem Ghetto bei Baron Hirsch—äh...
David Boder: . . . äh...und sie weg geschickt?
Jacob Button: In einem, äh...
David Boder: In einem Lager, or in einem Ghetto?
Jacob Button: Hat man sie erst in einem Ghetto versammelt, neben der, von dem Bahnhof von Saloniki, äh, und, äh, in wöchentlichen oder täglichen Transporten von 3.000 bis, äh, 3.500 Mann nach—Schlesien, nach Oberschlesien gesandt hat. Ich konnte persönlich von einem, von einem, äh, Deutschen, privat, nachher er—
David Boder: Erfahren...
Jacob Button: . . . erfahren, dass Juden nach Auschwitz versandt wurden.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Jacob Button: Und man machte mich aufmerksam, dass es sich von einer Vertilgung bei der Arbeit, bei der auf Wanderung weisen gehandelt—handeln sollte. Als die spanisch—, spanischen Juden eingeladen wurden, um ihnen etwas zu mitzuteilen von der deutschen Polizisten, bin ich schließlich angestellt bei dieser Versammlung und konnte mich verstecken, und die Möglichkeit später zu finden, nach Athen zu fahren.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jacob Button: Als ersten Unglück hatte ich, dass mir ein griechischer Matrose, ein, ein, äh—ein Schiff—, ein Kapitän von einem, äh, von einem Segelschiff mich, äh, betrogen hat, und hat mir, meine Frau und meine zwei Kinder, meiner, äh...
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Button: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Nun, geht’s weiter?
Jacob Button: Nein.
David Boder: Ja, am Ufer, jetzt was hat er Ihnen getan?
Jacob Button: Hat mir verlassen und meine Sachen genommen und mein Geld hat er mir am Ufer auch schon...
David Boder: Weg genommen...
Jacob Button: Weg genommen. Solche...
David Boder: Also, sind Sie dann mit Ihrer Frau und Ihre Kinder am Ufer geblieben?
Jacob Button: Ich bin, ich bin am Ufer geblieben mit meine Frau und zwei Kindern, zwei kleine Kinder von sechs und acht Jahren, und sollte nach—, nachher in der judenreinen, wie die Deutschen sagt—, das sagten, Saloniki wiederkommen.
David Boder: Ja. Wohin haben Sie denn gehen wollen mit dem Kapitän?
Jacob Button: Ich möchte, ich möchte nach, eh, Piräus fahren, wo in einem Teil von Griechenland, wo die italienischen, unter italienischen Herrschaft war...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Und dort kei—, noch keine Maßnahmen ge—, Maßnahmen gegen die Juden getroffen wurden.
David Boder: Ja. Und so haben Sie Ihre Sachen gepackt?
Jacob Button: Und ich hatte das, war es so, so vorbereitet, so wegzufahren und wurde im letzten Moment noch—betrogen und bin weg gelassen worden.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Also, ich hatte glücklicherweise einige griechische Freunde, die mich geholfen haben, und wenn ich wieder in der Stadt gekommen bin, konnte ich mich verstecken und nach ein, drei Tagen wieder noch etwas zu versuchen, nach Athen zu fahren. Auch in diesem Falle wurde ich im, äh, Eisenbahn, in der Eisenbahn—festgenommen wurde, weil, äh, ein Mann mich erkannt hat als Jude, und machte drei Monaten Verhaftung in einem [noise]—in einem Gefängnis von, äh, einem deutschen Gefängnis in Saloniki.
David Boder: Ja, und wo sind Sie...
Jacob Button: Und Frau mir...
David Boder: Man hat Sie im Zug verhaftet?
Jacob Button: Ja.
David Boder: Und wo sind Ihre Frau und die Kinder gegangen?
Jacob Button: Glücklicherweise meine Frau und meine Kinder wurden nicht dann erkannt, die waren nicht neben...
David Boder: . . . mir...
Jacob Button: . . . mir, und dann sind sie weiter fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Ich wurde verhaftet und man hat mich von diesem, und äh, Ge—, mi—, mit, äh, mit großer Strenge behandelt, wir waren acht Tagen in einem Gefängnis einem Pro—, an einem Stadt von der Provinz Mazedonien, der, und nachher, nachher wurden wir von der deutschen Geheimpolizei in Saloniki gegangen, und dort wurden wir in einem Gefängnis ge—, weiter geleitet, wo wir vier Monaten geblieben sind.
David Boder: Nach dem, und wo ist Ihre Frau und die Kinder gewest?
Jacob Button: Meine Frau und meine Kinder konnten nach Athen weiter, weiter fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Ich wurde, nach vielen Bemühungen und, der spanischer Gesandtschaft wurde ich befreit.
Jacob Button: Und, no, war ich auch frei...
David Boder: War das schon mit die Franco-Regierung, war die spanische Gesandtschaft nicht mit von der Franco-Regierung?
Jacob Button: Ja, doch....
David Boder: Aber sie haben sich für die Juden eingesetzt?
Jacob Button: Als spanischer Staatsangehöriger habe ich von seiner, äh,...
David Boder: Haben Sie denn Ihre...
Jacob Button: . . . von seiner Hilfe, von seiner Hilfe, äh,...
David Boder: Äh, haben Sie gehabt, tatsächlich...
Jacob Button: Ja, diese Hilfe der Gesandtschaft gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Ich—wurde...
David Boder: Und Sie wurden befreit?
Jacob Button: Ich wurde befreit, aber inzwischen hatte ich, äh, wurde ich schwer behandelt von den deutschen, äh...Poliz—
David Boder: Polizisten...
Jacob Button: Polizisten, von der Gestapo behandelt, und man hat mich, äh...versucht zu...[unverständlich] [ man hat mich...?]
David Boder: Ermorden?
Jacob Button: [unverständlich] [nein, nicht ermorden ich weiß nicht...was da war und was...?]
David Boder: Aha. Man hat Sie gefoltert, man hat Sie tortiert, tortourt—nicht wahr?
David Boder: [In English] They tortured.
David Boder: [In German] Sie wollten wissen, wo Ihre Sachen und wo Ihr Familie war.
Jacob Button: Oh, oh, und wo meine, meine, meine Kinder und meine Frau, und was ich von anderen Sachen betreffend der Juden, der Juden wusst.
David Boder: Und haben Sie was gesagt?
Jacob Button: Und—ich habe nicht das gesagt, man hat mich äh [menacie, mena?]
David Boder: Man hat mir gedroht, man hat Ihnen gedroht...
Jacob Button: Man hat man hat mir gedroht, mich zu befragen und zu töten und zu...aber ich...
David Boder: Hat man Sie geschlagen?
Jacob Button: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Man hat, man hat, man hat mich geschlagt, und ich habe das nicht gesagt, was ich wusste, wegen der Meinigen.
David Boder: Aha. Wieso, sie wollten wissen, wo Ihre Familie ist?
Jacob Button: Ja.
David Boder: Wollten Ihre Familie mit Sie schieden, hat Ihre Ihnen, Ihre Familie Ihnen nichts geschickt? Haben Sie nicht sowieso gewusst?
Jacob Button: Ich, ich wusste, ich, äh, ich war absolut getrennt von meiner Familie, ich hatte keine...
David Boder: Ja, Sie hatten keinen Kontakt, das...
Jacob Button: Ich persönlich hatte kein Kontakt, aber die Deutschen wollten...
David Boder: Wissen...
Jacob Button: Wissen, wer hat uns, äh, die Papiere gegeben zu...
David Boder: Ah so, von der Gesandtschaft.
Jacob Button: Nein, nicht von der Gesandtschaft, wer hat uns die Papiere gegeben, um in den deutschen Zug einzusteigen und, äh, nach Athen zu, zu fahren, ohne, ohne Erlaubnis.
David Boder: Hm. Nun?
Jacob Button: Also, in Athen bin ich wieder nach vier Monaten wieder gegeht, und haben mei—, die Meinigen gefunden, inzwischen hatten die Deutschen dort die Griechen, Juden wieder in Athen auf—, äh, gezählt und, äh, sollten sich, äh, wöchentlich bei der, äh...
David Boder: Polizei melden...
Jacob Button: . . . Synagoge, bei der, bei dem im Bethaus, jeden, jede Woche kommen und sich anzumelden, und im März dreiund—, äh, dreiundvierzig, im—im Monat März vierundvierzig, nicht dreiundvierzig, wurden sie gefangen und nach zwei Tagen wurden sie...
David Boder: Wer wurde gefangen?
Jacob Button: Die griechischen Juden, die sich bei der...
David Boder: Synagoge meldeten...
Jacob Button: . . . Synagoge meldeten, um sich, äh, wurden gefangen und nachher—hatte man die Adressen von den anderen Juden, die in Athen wohnten und überhaupt von den Spaniern, hat man sie zuhause nächtlich verhaftet.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Button: Man, man hat uns erstens in einer, ein Gefängnis ge—...
David Boder: Hat man Sie auch verhaftet?
Jacob Button: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: Man hat Sie wieder verhaftet?
Jacob Button: Man hat...
David Boder: Und Ihre Frau und die Kinder?
Jacob Button: Mein—, meine Frau und meine zwei jungen Kinder hat man auch mit mir verhaftet, wir waren auch da in der Gefängnis, in der Nähe von Athen, in [Caetari?] versammelt, dort, dort hatten wir die...den Besuch von den Gesandten, von den spanischen Gesandten in Athen gehabt, und man hat mich, äh, hat man uns gesagt, dass die Deutschen ihnen versprochen haben, uns nach Spanien zu senden—werden.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Aber, am 2. April...
David Boder: Vierundvierzig...
Jacob Button: Vierundvierzig hat man uns von dem Gefängnis von Caetari [?] aus auf den Bahnhof von Athen gesandt, äh, dort warn, waren wir mit andere—Wagon mit, die plombiert waren und andere Juden dort vorhanden, hat man uns...hat man uns be—, gefordert, wie aufgefordert, hinaufzusteigen, und wurden mit selbem Transport nach Deutschland geschickt, geschickt.
David Boder: Was für ein Transport waren Sie?
Jacob Button: Ein Teil von den Wagen, plombierte, das waren, äh, Loren [?]—Waren-Waggons, von, äh...
David Boder: Es, ja—Gü— Güterzüge...
Jacob Button: Gü—, Güter—, Güterzüge...
David Boder: Transportzüge...
Jacob Button: Güterwaggons war...war wir...
David Boder: Die Waggons waren ganz zugeschlossen?
Jacob Button: War, waren geschlossen und, äh...
David Boder: Plomben vom außen...
Jacob Button: Vom außen war, warn auch Plomben. Wir hatten von der [Mission?] vom Roten Kreuz etwas Brot und einige Pakete im Waggon, wo wir zweiunddreißig Personen in meinem Waggon waren,—da warn ander’ Waggon wo vierzig Personen schon noch dort waren, und wir machten eine lange Reise von sieben Tagen von, äh, Athen nach, nach Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Waren Ihre Frau und Ihre Kinder mit Ihnen?
Jacob Button: Mit, mit, mit meiner Frau und meinen zwei jungen Kindern und meinem Bruder auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Wir...
David Boder: Und das war im selben Waggon?
Jacob Button: Im selben, im selben Waggon waren wir. Und...
David Boder: Ja, und warten Sie, hat man den Waggon losgemacht, dass die Leute rausgehen können, oder was...
Jacob Button: Nach, äh, zwei Tagen von der Reise konnten wir einmal von dem Waggon hinaussteigen, und könnten die...die...
David Boder: . . . den Schmutz?
Jacob Button: Den Schmutz—weg—, äh...
David Boder: Wegräumen...
Jacob Button: Wegwerfen, wegwerfen, und, äh, etwas, äh, Wasser holen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Mit uns waren auch, mit uns, im griechischen Teil sind wir noch ein anderen Transport, die zu den unsern, äh, mit, äh...verbunden...
David Boder: . . . mit Ihnen verbunden war, ja?
Jacob Button: Verbunden wurde...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Und wir fahrten nach...durch, äh, Serbien, Österreich nach Deutschland.
Jacob Button: . . . und Ungarn, und Ungarn, fuhr—, fahrten wir nach Deutschland. In Ungarn habe ich, äh, hatten wir gesehen, bei, im April 44, die ersten Ungarn, die den Stern....
David Boder: . . . schon da trugen. [?]
Jacob Button: . . . trugen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Und haben die Möglichkeit gehabt, mit ein zu sprechen und man hat uns gesagt, dass uns in den letzten Tagen—wie wie, was für Gesetze und die Maßnahmen gegen den Juden in, äh...
David Boder: Ungarn...
Jacob Button: In, in äh...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Angewandt wurden?
Jacob Button: Angewandt, angewandt wurden.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Von unserm Transport wurde ein Teil, ein, der größte Teil von dem, äh, Transport abgesondert, in, äh, einer ungarischen Grenzstadt, und wurde nach anderen Richtung weiter...
David Boder: Geschickt.
Jacob Button: Geschickt.
David Boder: Wissen Sie nicht wo Sie geschickt wurden?
Jacob Button: Wussten nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Aber die, die Leute hatten keine große Hoffnung, und sie wussten, und sie wussten, dass selbst nach Oberschlesien und in Auschwitz die gesamte
David Boder: Wer [?]
Jacob Button: Gesandt werden.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Button: Unser Zug mit einigen Waggonen fuhr weiter nach Deutschland und wir...trafen ein in, äh, Belsen—dort stiegen wir ab von den Waggon und die Deutschen zwangten uns...
David Boder: Waren Sie noch immer mit Ihrer Frau und Ihren Kindern?
Jacob Button: Mit mit meiner Frau und meinen zwei Kindern war ich noch. Und die Deutschen zwangten, zwang—, zwangten uns, auszusteigen und in, äh, die Strecke von der, von dem Bahnhof bis zum Lager zu Fuß, der Alte und Kinder, und, äh, Männer wie Frauen, zu Fuß zu machen.
David Boder: Wie weit war das ungefähr?
Jacob Button: Es war etwa sieben Kilometer weit von dem Bahnhof.
David Boder: Hm.
David Boder: Nun?
Jacob Button: Es dann wieder, wir sind in dem Lager eingetroffen und wir fanden dort auch einige griechische Juden aus Saloniki. Man sagte uns, dass es in einem sehr strengen Lager angekommen sind, und, äh, sagte uns auch, dass es früher auch andere Juden aus Saloniki von spanischer Staatsangehörigkeit dort gewesen sind, aber diese Leute, sie waren vor drei Monaten von dem Lager weg ge—, weg gegangen. Wussten nicht genau, nach welcher Richtung und wo.
Jacob Button: Ich bin im Lager mit meiner Familie, meiner Frau und meinen zwei Kinder, genau ein Jahr lang geblieben.
David Boder: Hat man Sie erlaubt, zusammen zu sein?
Jacob Button: Wir lebten in großen Baracken, Holzbaracken...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Und fanden dort auch polische—einige dreihundert bis vierhundert polische Juden...
David Boder: Männer und Frauen?
Jacob Button: Männer und Frauen, einige Kinder...
David Boder: Im selben, äh, Raum?
Jacob Button: Im, äh, einem benachbarten Block, im benachbarten Block, es waren polische Juden, die zu der südamerikanischen, äh, Staatsangehörigkeit hatten und als Neutrale nicht zu der Arbeit verpflichtet...
David Boder: Werden konnten?
Jacob Button: Wurden.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Man be—, wenn—, wir hatten eine Bewachung von deutschen Soldaten, und jeden Morgen sollten wir auf dem Appell herauskommen, und, äh, man machte uns often zwei, drei, Stunden und eine Stunde, Winter, Kleinen und Großen, Frauen und Männer, warten, wenn etwas nicht in Ordnung war. Wann die [Zahlen?] nicht fand und wenn verhafteten. Wir—man hat uns versprochen, dass wir die Möglichkeit haben werden, mit dem Auslande zu, in, äh...
David Boder: . . . kommunizieren?
Jacob Button: In Verbindung zu kommen, aber es waren nur Vers—, äh, nur...
David Boder: Versprechen....
Jacob Button: . . . nur leere Versprechen, und wir hatten niemals die Möglichkeit, mit, äh, mit der Auswelt zu—, in Verbindung zu kommen. Man, als Nahrung hatten wir die denen, die Nahrung, die jede, die, der, die jede Internierte hatte. Unsere Küche war nicht besser, oder nicht schlechter wie den andern, weil das Ganze nicht schlechter sein wie sie war. Wir hatten früh ein warmes Wasser, die man, äh, Infusion von Kaffee nannte und gar nichts mit Kaffee zu tun hatte. Man, am Mittag konnte sehr hungrige Person von was letzten Monat, konnte eine, eine Speise von eine, eine Suppe, die von etwas—eine Gemüse...
David Boder: Ja?
Jacob Button: Die man...
David Boder: Nun ja, so, mit etwas Gemüse gemischt, nun?
Jacob Button: Und, und, Gräser [?] und so weiter das war unsere Nahrung—man hatte 300 Gramm Brot pro Person und später hatten wir nur 250 und den letzten Tage noch gar nichts, und da sind wieder dasselbe warme Wasser und nichts weiter, das war die Nahrung, die unsere Kräfte herabsetzte, und in den letzten Tagen wurden wir gezwungen, hungrig um ohne Essen zu, zu leben ohne Bewegungen [?] zu machen und an, äh, an Hunger zu, zu sterben, weil unsere Kräfte waren durchaus...
David Boder: Geschwächt?
Jacob Button: Geschwächt.
David Boder: Nun, was haben die Kinder in solch einem Lager getan?
Jacob Button: Die Kinder konnten, wenn wir, ich und meine Frau zusammen waren, konnten von unseren Anteil etwas mehr haben.
David Boder: Aber was haben die sonst getan, gelesen, gespielt?
Jacob Button: Die Kinder wie die Großen hatten keine Zwangsarbeit zu leisten.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Ich konnt, ich kann persönlich sagen, was ich um mir gesehen habe.
David Boder: Aber was haben Ihre eigenen Kinder getan, was haben die den ganzen Tag getan?
Jacob Button: Die Kinder, die...
David Boder: Waren die erlaubt, draußen zu gehen?
Jacob Button: Draußen, wo draußen, wir waren drauß, neben, äh, wir warn zwischen, äh, Baracken draußen...
David Boder: Baracken. Ja.
Jacob Button: Und die Kinder konnten sich von dem, äh...
David Boder: Baracken...
Jacob Button: Von den Baracken, weit davon, 20, 25 Meter weit, weiter, weiter gehen, um weiter kommen und, äh...
David Boder: Sagen Sie, Herr Button, wo sind Sie, äh, wo sind jetzt weiter Ihre Frau und Kinder jetzt?
Jacob Button: Meine Frau und meine Kinder sind jetzt in Paris, wo ich auch noch bin, und lebe noch in einem Centre de [unverständlich] von der Fédération des Sociétés Juives de France.
David Boder: Sie wohnen nicht in diesem Hause?
Jacob Button: Ich wohne in diesem Haus.
David Boder: Und die Frau und die Kinder?
Jacob Button: Und meine Kinder auch, ja.
David Boder: Die, Sie wohnen hier, Sie haben hier ein Zimmer?
Jacob Button: Ja ich habe hier ein Zimmer—ich möchte etwas...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: . . . sagen über die schlechten Behandlung von den Juden und den andern Internierten in Bergen-Belsen...
Jacob Button: . . . und—wo ich Frauen und Männer gesehen habe, die im Winter und im Schnee und, äh, großer Kälte—große Bretter und einem Wagen, äh...
David Boder: . . . geschleppt haben...
Jacob Button: . . . in Wagen gestreckt haben, die früher,—an die man nur, äh, nur Pferde und, äh...
David Boder: Maulesel...
Jacob Button: Mau—, Maulesel, äh...
David Boder: Gespannt hat...
Jacob Button: Ge—, gespannt hat. Wurden unter sehr schlechten...
David Boder: Bedingungen...
Jacob Button: Bedingungen, wurden sehr schlechten Bedingungen, äh, ge— von Männern und, äh, und Frauen geschlä—, geschlägt...ich habe gesehen, wie deutschen Frauen die Internierte zu Arbeit härteten und, äh, schlugen, fertig mit großen...
David Boder: Peitschen...
Jacob Button: Mit Peitschen und, äh, Holz—, äh, und...
David Boder: . . . —stöcken...
Jacob Button: . . . und Holzstöcke—und ich habe auch gesehen, dass eine einige Internierte auch wie vielleicht Deutsch oder—weiß nicht wovon andere Nationalitäten warn, sind die dazu gebraucht wurden, um die anderen Ju—, Juden zu, zu schlagen. Ich, äh...
David Boder: Waren diese Juden, die Sie geschlagen haben?
Jacob Button: Nein, es...
David Boder: Nein, andere Häftlinge?
Jacob Button: Es, es waren andere Häftlinge, Deutsche oder Ro—, Russen oder weiß ich nicht so genau, wie...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Was sie waren...die die Juden, die die Juden schlugen. Ich habe auch vor— gesehen, dass sie eine Frau, die ein, ein, ein werig, ein wenig, äh, etwas Brot geben wollte und und Salz, wurde von einer deutschen, äh, Gestapo-Frau gesehen worden und sie hat auf sie, auf den Kopf so heftig geschlagen, dass ich sie nach zwei Tagen nicht wieder draußen kommen sah, und später erfahren habe, dass sie tot—tot gefallen ist.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, Herr Button, was planen Sie jetzt zu tun? Was werden Sie jetzt tun, wo wollen Sie gehen oder bleiben Sie in Paris?
Jacob Button: Ich habe erstens mich zum Palästina an—, angemeldet und möchte wo ich nach Palästina—
David Boder: Sie haben sich, noch mal, Sie haben sich für Pal...
Jacob Button: Ich habe mich zum Palästina angemeldet und wollte erstens nach Palästina fahren, wo ich auch andern Verwandten hatte.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Button: Ich warte leider ein ganzen Jahr hier und hab ich nicht meine Bewilligung, um nach Palästina zu fahren, gehabt. Ich musste mich bemühen, etwas hier in Frankreich als Arbeit zu finden, und meine Möglich—, Lebensmöglichkeit zu—
David Boder: Zu—, fördern oder...
Jacob Button: Zu versichern.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool number 25, spoken by Mr. Jacob Button, a Spanish Jew born in Greece, he is now doing some work, he expects to go to Palestine. Illinois Institute of Technology recording.